foreign
[Music]
hit Among Us is taking the next step the
cult game is now to be released as a
series according to an exclusive report
from variety the developer Studio inner
sloth is working with cbsi animation
Productions to turn the game into an
animated series The Among Us series is
of course based on the concept of the
game the crew of a spaceship is
infiltrated by an alien shapeshifter who
causes confusion sabotages the ship and
wants to kill everyone the question is
will the crew succeed in hunting down
the so-called imposter or will his
diabolical plan work the series is being
produced by the animation studio
titmouse titmouse is best known for its
series big mouth and Star Trek lower
decks the main character is Owen Dennis
who previously worked on the Cartoon
Network series Infinity train at this
time it is not known which network or
streaming service will show Among Us
with talks currently ongoing the game
Among Us was first released in 2018 and
experienced a massive surge in
popularity in 2020 topping download
charts almost everywhere in the fourth
quarter of 2020 the game had nearly 500
million monthly active users over 4
billion views on YouTube and more than
1.22 billion sessions on Twitch many
fans are certainly excited to see how
the popular game will do as a series as
soon as more details and a possible
release date for the among a series are
known we will let you know of course
[Music]
thank you